皆さんはこそのピノご存じでしょうかつのピノ買うと僕までに星型のピノがすごい低い
確率で入ってるらしいでございますあの今回僕がしたいのはですねちょっと雅紀にね
すごいハッピーな卓球料
してあげようと思っておりまして開けます
全部欲しいのビジョン
はぁトート版の話です都市型の箕面が入っている出現率は4.8%
22箱分の1かカート型ピノはなんて2%33個分の1をなんでもいいよもう欲しいん
じゃ
なるじゃなければいいんですよまあ仮に星型のピノが3つハート形のピザは3つ入って
いるとなるとターンと8265マン7170
6面の1の確率でございます遠く82605710076分の一の確率が目の前で
起きると何ら出身で倒れても不思議ではない状況です真聖
喜ばせんと何より嬉しいと思えるとジャック4ポケットするよ
まあ
何気ないしちゃいますよ我々が彩ってあげましょう
横慌ててぜ準備しないと本来は企画始まらないのでまずは機能を探していきますでは
取れず3 no な家の名湯後に入るんだから多分コレ買いすぎてやって連投大きい者
をかける前にピノを届けるはどれ z ここに日の151個あるので全然六太食べた
時点でも完成するので時計はにとりあえず早く見つけますはいよし
探そう
あっはヤバイマジこれスピードだ
パッカーだめだわああ
ちょっとポトフと度カードああああああでも出たよ岡山さて2%をものにしました
ハート1個でましたすぐ保存してくるんん
[音楽]
ん
やばいやばいよ
[音楽]
やばい
オーナー
何込めてだおっ出費とねこれほどってだぞ
[音楽]
ああああああ
[拍手]
me
バッハ
本当に町まずやばいこれ本物よこれね
早くほとんどどうぞ今限定が3つ出たらだと3つ
出せばとりあえず天文学的な数字のフィードが挙げられます
うん
ああああああああ
4つめてましたすべて子供なんか持ってれば ok ですよねこの数でしょ
平気ですよ音までうっかりくださいですよね
グーン
ん
やばいちょっとやばいやばいやばいうーん
[音楽]
山
ちょっと外房数そっ
例えばこんな残りズッコ中で1個でも捕手館ハートが出ればミッションクリアです
なかったら割れでほんと a
あっはぁっ
ああああああ
炙ったよずっとでも料理はれだ
高さはその手でてくれ全部黒にまとめているってえっとボニー
これで今年の夏を乗り切れるよ実際 ok
はいはいこれで今年のピノに困りませんとそんなもんですっ
ちょっとなんていうわけで途中でやめたんですけどもとりあえずむっつめて星ナビ動画
ごっこパートが一つ
全部欲しい2猫なあー
お願いますからここまで来るともう全部欲しいのほうがいい
まず手を上げてないので打っポリマーちょっととりあえず開けてみて
ここまで来るなんか全部その p の方がいいんじゃないかと思うんで持ち上げてみ
ます
ああああああ
あっはい
素人物
バーっ熟悉パンッ
全部あ
[音楽]
年末でもつけてた野望がない方ありました
星野ぴのあ
ってさぁ
musmus 埋めてた
出てたのごめんねあずき起こしてちょっとどうでも渡したい物だってさ
出来れば今私たいないいじゃあちょっと再建にいくね ok 座近くになったことを
連絡します
んじゃねぇ
元から空いてると思うんだ海や山ピリピリは行ってほしいからお腹の時する買いたい
まず横から中身だけ取りますすっと
よしこれで無事全部星のピノでございますこのままケースに戻すってで蓋をしてノリで
くっつけます
ok 確率で言うと言って僕133079,9004分の1の確率で出現する
まほろセノハチ7歩吸ってるんでございますやばいよ本当にそれぐらいの城もう撮っ
てっ
俺の最高の後半今先にプレゼントするっていきますいて下佐々木と待ち合わせ場所に来
ましたもうあそこに埋まってるんですけども
しんじゃないか15000語ってますけどね
いきましょうん
これ実は付属しません
me
僕がアップ怖いとか言わなきゃいけこれからもよろしくっていうを込めてこれを
プレゼントします
ん
[音楽]
メットをかけてみてください
えっ全部欲しい
えっ
絶対厚みたじゃんっ
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ
普通くらい混ぜこれマジ15000飾ってるというわけだ
満足して頂けたかい